die firma sheldon mein name das hemme
das ist der kollegen lahm und wir sind
hier für die badsanierung belegen heute
fußboden heute haben folgende situation
jahren davor nicht den waschtisch hier
kommt das mitzählen
wir sind heute hier um die
fußbodenheizung zulegen kann alles klar
[Applaus]
eine fußbodenheizung verlegt waren sie
angeschlossen und sie ist dicht und da
müssen wir fertig für heute ich habe
jetzt in dem zb fertiggemacht her
das gemisch das ist der kollege ja heute
und wir waren jetzt insgesamt drei
stunden hier gewesen h
wir haben die fußbodenheizung verlegt
angeschlossen und auf dichtigkeit
überprüft sondern bekomme ich bitte hier
unten eine unterschrift von drei stunden
vielen dank